right uh knee in the top eight barely
got in uh beat up eye musician to get in
here uh but obviously lost to infested
earlier in the bracket
and look at this i asked for it and we
got it knee with lydia
uh yes going up against the geese
boy oh boy
all right and i'm wondering what knee
has uh in store
yes
this is i assume we're gonna see a lot
of political storm from lydia it's like
this long range forward yeah
um
though you know
geese's counter though yeah i don't know
but then again
doesn't really use the counter much i
don't think we've seen him using camera
at all this might be yeah well uh he'll
bring it out in those clutch moments
though right i mean yeah i hope so he
has done that and that is it just takes
it erases your life bar so
we'll see we'll see if me will be
careful anyone's going to be careful
it's me
establishing their offensive pattern
yeah
think about this
and knee definitely
finally down four counter hit yeah
that really seems to be one of like the
uh the trademarks of them man that space
it was so good
even better oh my god
oh my god
that just visually looked crazy
it's too
yeah it's all wise honey tweeting out
that he thinks lydia is
the uh best female character in the game
that namco's ever created
oh wow okay yeah i've heard it i've
heard such as like right oh yes that
demo man gets blocked
big punish here from mario
nice
juicy combo here
two bars meter
yeah oh
needle
of course do it again do it again yes
he had that rage boost there's so much
damage they're canceling it down for
excuse me a bar oh i just tried for a
forward tour there
did you see how small that size was for
the air fireball there that was so clean
yeah yeah it's like that wasn't enough
i'm coming in
yeah
yeah i can't do that with the eddy
oh get out of here girl
wow he got carried he still was able to
get that are you kidding oh my god that
was so optimal no
cliff that combo that was ridiculous oh
my god oh like no way he's gonna like
get that wall combo and finish
he used the weird point
he got the whole round with it
yeah
oh here we go
there's a big combo with the mix up
following
oh the wall bound all right
oh no oh okay block and me with rage
very dangerous right now
and he would wave but yeah well's got
almost two bars devil
yeah demoman
going for the rage
okay oh yeah yeah
final round getting the relief whenever
someone uses their race
and he's got two bars this is great
because it's from oil here
oh here we go
combo yeah
and this is this is geese with meter
and the wall combo in this small stage
how much damage was that got another bar
too
yes
yeah lydia is not like the comeback
she's not like a pocket bomb or you're
always feeling around with your
lifeguard or like
that's scary because he was in that
moment before right he was you know uh
he got
he had me and he was in rage and he was
uh it was in a position okay position
where he could do that demo man again
remember he did the devilman two times
in a row and basically he this time he
did it once and you know demo man with
like
uh with rage booth does so much damage
right and then after you know he got up
the second after that i think he was
just like oh he i guess he could do it
again that's what he did last time and
yeah he got hit by uh he got hit by the
blue stuff
almost made that comeback yeah or yeah
yeah yeah and so that was ridiculous and
so the crazy thing about that situation
was he he took the first one right and
in that situation you've got a big
likely times winding down you don't have
to get up off the ground that's one of
the things about tekken right you don't
have to get up off the ground you can
just take inside or whatever lydia can
like hit you around and flip you over
and you can kind of get out of the
situation a little bit that way uh but
he got up like and i was like why did he
get up and as soon as he did there came
the rage driver he ducked for it right
uh yeah yeah
risky situation to put himself into
uh but honestly it paid out like
thankfully he had built up enough meter
you know going to a final round with
geese when you've got two bars that's a
great situation for you
yeah
yeah and uh
and yeah this is uh this is a quick uh
best of
three match so um yeah i'm oil just have
to win one more to take out me
but uh yeah
the raging storm at the end
oh yeah
he's using that meter
if you go back to the beginning of the
screen where we were talking about like
akuma and tekken you know and uh the
holders versus the zones and all this
stuff right like it's like that's
something you not use with a tekken
player like what do you mean a wake up
soup oh yeah you know that i can't get
through it's got invincibility what
yeah yeah brakes it's definitely a rule
breaker but it's so hyped what happens
because you never get a seat though yeah
it's so rare especially final round
final hit
yes
and the knee
pushing forward
sticking with the video
[Music]
yeah definitely
definitely knee was more offensive there
still pushing forward
yeah
pick an owner hit
whoa did you see that run
that was weird he stopped it too he
could have got a tackle out of it
[Music]
okay oh yes
oh tried up four four again yeah and
he's been going upward for uh quite a
bit
yeah it's because it's the mix right for
like that damn actually low
beautiful and already two rounds
up neat this is so fast
wow
yeah and moy has been like no meter
either
yeah he like haven't really done
anything look at this
board
[Applause]
yeah he's like just stay closer and just
kick him in the face bro yeah just the
basics oh big counter hit okay moyo
coming back here
saying i don't want to get nowhere i'm
brown here
oh
oh
yeah yeah
[Music]
and just like that lydia pulling through
for knee uh you know committing to the
character choice there uh and that was
such an interesting choice for the throw
attempt right like i mean yeah yeah
tekken 7 throws you know we've talked
about plenty it's not it's not that
difficult to break especially the
highest levels of the game especially
when you have a character like geese
where it's not really a mix-up it's like
just a regular grab or one plus two uh
you know for a tech veteran like me
i'm gonna guess he's gonna break that
most often like unless you're trying to
use it to switch positions on a throw
escape or something but in that
situation so odd you know it's such a
risky choice uh but regardless me gets
the game uh ties it up final game
incoming lose a bracket here so knee
facing elimination still
uh both of them are facing liquidation
obviously but obviously i know a lot of
you people in chat are probably big me
fans right so everyone wants to see me
do well in tournaments and uh right now
it's looking a little scary to be honest
it's looking very scary
yeah um he did uh he did come back a bit
he got his momentum back and definitely
knee played his game um you know where
you were talking about no political
storms or anything like it just just
you know hop kick at the right moment
you know just bait um beta whiff and hop
kick he got a ton of damage uh that that
game so we'll have to see um you know if
he sticks that he's definitely more uh
active and and pushing forward but um
but yeah this is the
this is the final game
all right precipice of fate
geese and lydia of course
what a dramatic i'm really shocking
super dramatic right depressive
who's getting thrown off this cliff you
know yeah
a president
yeah
all right
this is crazy we're getting into it
final game here with loyal versus knee
hey
yeah and
bit more active now
realizing that knee has adapted
yeah he's been establishing you know
this down by three hopkins mix-up game
uh and he's having really good success
both obviously pretty punishable so you
gotta be right
on your wrist
yeah just
it's a bunch of jabs right now
stepping nothing crazy but knee with
rage
oh get down for it
there's the rage and this
this is gonna get wall damn it's a
problem
oh it doesn't finish it out quite yet
let's jump in jump come here using the
meter
yeah he delayed that low key just a
little bit said me wouldn't go for like
a quick little perry beautiful time
again
and boy with the first round there uh
but he's got to be careful man every
time that knees got rage you know boy is
ducking for those down back threes and
he's being called these rape drives
just getting out of there
oh just stuffs the uh down down back
three
oh man knee getting the position now
burns the meter
oh good duck
but knee with rage air fireball
oh just this is wrong
i'm so careful
set point your knee facing elimination
right now
needs to make a three-round comeback
gets the hockey goal
block's good
yeah
uh-oh
oh boyle got a bar now got a bar now
yeah oh man
you could be dead
he's got rage too with the bounce
he needs a miracle there's a raider kill
we drop it somehow that's what it was
hoping for it's not gonna happen though
yeah
knee is out of here
out of here
ggs thanks for playing me goes home at
seventh place
boyle advancing into the top five of the
tekken online down 2021 for korea wow
wow wow
yeah that was uh
that was really good stuff from oil
that was crazy yeah you were talking
about the the the mid parry you know the
one that doesn't although we don't
really how he doesn't really use it
right but you know yeah
you know that's if you have a strong
move and uh you know you you can you can
also save it too right and sometimes at
this this high level you you gotta do
that and yeah that's how he took that
game